[Musique]
lui m'a mis un goût particulier à lui
marqué le goût on va dire riesch est en
fait une mamie s'est traduit du japonais
comme un goût délicieux c'est vraiment
quand on mange par exemple un bouillon
de poulet puis ont dû nous c'est bon
c'est vraiment cette sensation là alors
c'est un peu salée mais surtout ça fait
vraiment comme riches en bouche le miso
très bons amis le parmesan certaines
charcuteries mon premier souvenir de
mamie c'est vraiment la salsa qu'elle ma
grand-mère faisait avec des tomates des
light ou des ingrédients riche en
humanité et ça c'est vraiment comme où à
la fin tout ce qu'on veut c'est faire
waouh c'est vraiment bon
on est habitué depuis qu'on est tout
petit à dire que y'a 4 go 2 go de base
et les mamies c'est un cinquième est
donc en art et le salé et sucré l'acide
l'amer et finalement en 5e l'umami qui
se rajoutent
ses sensations qui on peut décomposer un
trois morceaux 1 ce que ça va donner
plus de richesses as commence donc sa
valeur au c'est tout le reste en
deuxième lieu ça va faire saliver
davantage et en troisième lieu ça va
aussi donner de la longueur à tout les
goûts
dans la rome antique on savait que les
sauce de poisson fermenté avait un goût
savoureux mais c'est en 1908 qu'un
chimiste japonais comprend pourquoi le
bouillon dashi et si savoureux il
découvre la présence de glutamate ou
acide glutamique dans les ags comme hbo
il ya des produits qui en ont déjà
naturellement à l'état libre comme le
lait maternel
la tomate les champignons les asperges
ya en contiennent déjà mais il
yad'autres acide glutamique qui peut
être produit lors de la fermentation
comme dans la sauce soya mais sinon des
plats classiques par exemple des bonnes
parts avec une sauce tomate et du
fromage parmesan râpé par dessus ça
vient de faire une bombe une amie dans
un plat on vient là la théorie de
cuisine moléculaire qui fait que quand
on cumule deux choses qui marchent bien
ensemble on fait pas un peu sale de ont
fait un peu sans égal 3
le chef cédric charon est fasciné par la
cuisine japonaise dans son restaurant
des gammes il cherche à susciter le une
amie dans une foule de plat en utilisant
des marinades et des fermentations
fut mise aux qui ferment à tes deux ans
donc on va se rapprocher d'une texture
de parmesan un peu mais c'est ce qui te
fantastique c'est que c'est complexe
effectivement à décrire parce que ça
commence on a comme une touche de sel
puis après belgique comme marie ferrand
si le parmesan ne goûte permanent de
l'élevage à la base de ce repas ou mamie
mais quand on fait un parmesan avec qui
veulent devenir parce qu'il ya une job
de fermentation de bactéries qui se fait
mais ça ce processus là on peut le faire
avec un lait de soya sinon peut faire
fermenter fut pendant deux ans puis on
va chercher le même le même côté umami
qatar mais un peu avant le miso new game
is aux québécois celle émise au qu'on
peut trouver très facilement de ma mère
c'est tellement puissant comme goût
avec ce biseau vieilli trois ans cédric
prépare un bouillon réconfortant donc
infusion des algues jeta qu'est oignons
caramélisés gingembre haye cependant la
base toutes les recettes japonaise le
but du départ d'ali met les algues et le
cheetah qui s'est justement pour aller
chercher le glutamate présent mancelle
ces 2 ingrédients ensuite l'on veut
faire quelque chose d'un petit peu moins
traditionnel
qui le thème qu'ils ont fait par julien
de symbiose alimentaire moi je me sens
intéressant parce que l'on quand on
parlait de lou m'a mis dans la
charcuterie on va les chercher
le résident la charcuterie le feu dans
la cuisine japonaise on est capable
d'avoir des goûts extrêmement puissant
et riche sans l'utilisation des matières
grasses animales par exemple et avec une
simplicité d'ingrédients as we know me
fait signer d'un de savoir que
l'udc a pas de viande que rien là dedans
qu'on a ce goulot de charcuterie
c'est comme une une magie
cette magie se hume amis selon cédric
n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un équilibre
de saveurs comme ce steak de champignons
enoki où cette prune très particulière
c'est très prés salés ouais mais j'ai
trop souvent cerveau enregistre sa va
goûter soit une limousine cerise quand
je le vois pis on est on est très très
loin de sol mais à côté sucré en même
temps au dessus
pour déclencher ce fameux une mamie à la
maison on peut essayer en faisant retire
ses légumes on ajoutant des champignons
cuits et des sources fermenté assez plat
comme la source soya les sources de
poissons ou la sauce miso si on veut
goûter l'umami à son état le plus peur
ça suffit d'acheter à l'épicerie du
glutamate monosodique mais on nous
oppose y à une époque d'éviter ce
glutamate monosodique parce que c'était
mauvais pour la santé ça peut donner mal
à la tête
d'un point de vue médical sap a vraiment
été prouvé que ça existait une
intolérance au glutamate monosodique
donc voilà ça c'est 5e goût et mamies
merci beaucoup pour cette étonnante
dégustation